those listening or watching there's
going to be an exordium on aliens first
if you're mainly interested in the
foundations of physics
then look at the timestamps and view or
listen to accordingly
we're going to talk about aliens
why don't you tell us about the bentham
encounter from 1951
uh right so that that encounter
happened um in 1951
um graham bethune was um
he was a navy navy pilot they were
summoned to
iceland to reykjavik to
because the the in iceland they were
having problems with
a ufo operating in the area and
um i think it was operating in a maybe
near an airport or somewhere sensitive i
don't recall exactly what the difficulty
was
and they were summoned there to
basically check this out and help them
out with this
problem um they got there no
didn't see anything the thing with us
the thing was gone by that time
and they were heading back across the
atlantic from iceland
um toward newfoundland and
while they were flying um they had
saw lights on the surface of the water
on the ocean below
and it looked like city lights and at
first they thought they were they were
out of um off course and so they double
checked their course and realized no
they're on course and they thought well
there must be ships
maybe naval ships operating in the area
or something and
and um and as they got closer
the um these lights were basically was a
disc shaped light
a ring i guess and it appeared to be
under the water
and as they approached this thing this
thing shot up from the sea surface to
their altitude
in very short period of time like a
matter of a second or two
and the
and this it was basically a large
um large disk i think he described it as
being
a 300 feet across i probably i needed
i actually printed out my paper here too
and mine will fill some of these details
there's a lot of cases and
um yeah so it was several hundred feet
across um the disc was slightly below
their altitude so they could actually
see this disc
it had um like glowing around the
periphery
and as the object moved
um the the color of the light would
change so
um and i think it's been described as
looking like a plasma
so this object basically was with them
for several for several minutes they
basically steered
um the one of the one
one person wanted to steer toward it so
they they steered toward it
and um and eventually the thing took off
but it was seen by pretty much everybody
on on board um
i think they were like on the order of
20 people or so on board
who witnessed this thing so this thing
then took off and they estimated its
speed
um as it left to be about 1500 miles an
hour
which is about what was picked up on
radar they were close enough to
newfoundland that
they were able to detect this on radar
and they confirmed that later